Willkommen an der Landesverteidigungsakademie
in Wien. Mein Name ist Oberst Andreas Alexa,
ich bin Forscher und Lehrer für Militärlogistik
am Institut für Höhere Militärische Führung. In
diesem Video möchte ich Sie näher heranführen
an die Logistikunterstützung der russischen
Streitkräfte. Ich werde daher besonders
darauf eingehen - auf die Herausforderungen,
nämlich den Bedarf der Streitkräfte, die Distanzen
und den Raum und die Dauer des Krieges. Die erste
Herausforderung ist der Bedarf der Streitkräfte.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass sich ca. 200.000
russische Soldaten in der Ukraine bzw. im Umfeld
der Ukraine befinden, dann haben wir einen Bedarf
von circa 800 Tonnen Verpflegung pro Tag. Beim
Kraftstoff, der ebenfalls enorm ist der Bedarf,
das sind ca. vier Millionen Liter Kraftstoff
für ungefähr 120 Bataillonskampfgruppen,
die sich aktiv und direkt an Kampfhandlungen
beteiligen. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht,
dass eine Bataillonskampfgruppe für
fünf Tage autark ist - das heißt,
für fünf Tage Bestände mitführt, dann muss
spätestens am dritten Tag eine Wiederauffüllung
passieren. Das muss organisiert werden, das muss
auch bedeckt werden und da jetzt die Ukraine
natürlich keine logistische Unterstützung
für die russischen Streitkräfte leistet,
müssen diese Bedürfnisse der Streitkräfte aus
der strategischen Basis aus Russland nachgeführt
werden. Da kommen wir schon zur zweiten
Herausforderung - zu den Distanzen und zu
dem Raum. Also wie erwähnt, die strategische
Basis Russland muss leistungsfähig sein,
die strategische Basis Russland besteht
im Wesentlichen aus der Rüstungsindustrie,
aus der zivilen Wirtschaft und aus militärischen
Depots und Lager. Diese müssen aufgefüllt sein,
das wird sich in den nächsten Wochen zeigen,
welche Auswirkungen diese Sanktionen der
westlichen Staatengemeinschaft
auf die strategische Basis haben.
Eine weitere Herausforderung im Bereich
der Distanzen ist die Ukraine selber. Die
Logistik ist abhängig von Verbindungslinien, sei
es Straßen, sei es Eisenbahnlinien, Verkehrswege
oder sei es auch der Lufttransport. Wenn wir uns
die Ukraine hier geografisch betrachten, da gibt
es sehr viele leistungsfähige Eisenbahnlinien,
es gibt auch einige leistungsfähige Straßen und
es gibt auch zwei wesentliche Seeverbindungslinien
einmal nach Odessa und einmal hier nach Mariupol.
Eine Herausforderung bei den Verkehrslinien
ist, dass diese sicher sein müssen. Erste
Störaktionen in Belarus zeigen bereits,
dass es hier Herausforderungen für den
Eisenbahntransport von Norden Richtung Süden gibt.
Eine zweite Herausforderung ist in den russisch
okkupierten Gebieten, hier blassrot dargestellt.
Man stellte fest und man stellt auch fest, dass
die russischen Streitkräfte keine territoriale
Hoheit über dieses Gebiet haben. Das heißt,
es gibt nach wie vor Anschläge, es gibt Sprengung
von Brücken und es gibt auch eine Störung der
Eisenbahn. Das bedeutet, durch das Prinzip der
kleinen Nadelstiche versuchen die ukrainischen
Verteidiger, die Logistik, die Versorgung - alle
Anstrengungen der russischen Streitkräfte in
diesem Bereich zu minimieren und das wiederum
hat gewaltige Auswirkungen auf die Kampfmoral
der russischen Streitkräfte. Denn Sie müssen sich
nur vorstellen, bekommen Sie zwei Tage kein Essen,
bekommen Sie drei Tage kein Essen, bekommen
Sie keinen Sprit, das heißt, die Führung,
das Vertrauen in die Führung schwindet massiv und
das wird sich in den nächsten Tagen noch zeigen,
inwieweit das die russischen Streitkräfte wieder
ausgleichen können. Eine zweite Herausforderung im
Raum der Ukraine sind auch das schlechte Wetter,
Sprengung von Brücken und Feindbedrohung. All das
ergibt eine geringere Transportgeschwindigkeit,
wenn wir normal davon ausgehen, dass ein Konvoi
auf der Autobahn 60 bis 70 Stundenkilometer im
Durchschnitt fahren kann, dann verringert sich
hier die Geschwindigkeit auf 20 bis 30 Kilometer
pro Stunde. Das hat wiederum eine Auswirkung auf
die Umlaufleistung der Transporte - es müssen
mehr fahren, um die gleiche Anzahl an der Menge
zu transportieren. Immer wieder kommt die Frage,
warum die russischen Streitkräfte so massiv von
der Eisenbahn abhängig sind. Nun, das hat
natürlich zwei Gründe: Der eine Grund ist,
natürlich kann ich mit der Eisenbahn größere
Mengen, größere Tonnagen, zum Beispiel an Munition
oder Betriebsmittel transportieren. Der zweite
Grund ist augenscheinlicher, denn die russischen
Streitkräfte, die logistischen Elemente der
russischen Streitkräfte verfügen nicht über die
erforderliche Anzahl an Transportfahrzeugen. Und
daher, wenn man sich die Geografie des Konfliktes
hier ansieht - zum Beispiel die Angriffsrichtungen
und die Angriffsziele, da stellt man fest,
dass die Masse dieser Angriffe entlang oder in
Anlehnung an wichtigen Eisenbahnlinien erfolgte,
wie zum Beispiel hier im Südosten oder hier im
Norden. Daher sind auch die Verkehrsknotenpunkte
von so elementarer Bedeutung für die russischen
Streitkräfte, wie zum Beispiel Charkiw oder
Donezk. In den letzten Tagen hat sich der
Kampf um Mariupol hier intensiviert und
seit gestern beginnt auch ein Kampf um Odessa.
Warum diese zwei Städte? Auch aus logistischen
Hintergründen. Einerseits ein Seehafen, das
heißt Anbindung an den Seeweg und andererseits
ebenfalls leistungsfähige Eisenbahnlinien,
die hier von Süden nach Norden verlaufen.
Der letzte Punkt, die letzte Herausforderung
ist die Dauer. Anscheinend ist Russland davon
ausgegangen, dass es ein kurzer
Angriffskrieg wird. Daher hat man
möglicherweise die Bevorratung, die Ausstattung
der angreifenden Verbände mit logistischen
Ressourcen vernachlässigt. Allerdings ist
man auf Widerstand gestoßen. Die Folge war,
dass logistische Basen, hier in den Einsatzraum
- sprich in der Ukraine errichtet wurden,
sogenannte, man könnte auch sagen Pufferlager,
um hier erste Bedarfe abdecken zu können.
Allerdings müssen alle diese Einrichtungen,
die sind hier nur schematisch dargestellt,
gesichert werden und auch diese Sicherung bindet
wieder Kampfelemente, die man für andere Einsätze
eben nicht verwenden kann. Eine große Frage und
das wird sich in den nächsten Wochen noch zeigen,
wird sein, welche Auswirkungen auf das Zivilleben
hat denn die Bedarfsdeckung aus der strategischen
Basis Russland. Wenn man immer mehr Ressourcen
aus dem Land nimmt, das heißt, aus dem russischen
Heimatland, und in die Ukraine nachführt, wird
sich hier möglicherweise eine Herausforderung
für das zivile Leben in Russland selbst ergeben.
Ja, ich habe Ihnen versucht, in diesem Video den
Bedarf der Streitkräfte, die Distanz und Raum
und auch die Dauer darzustellen, zu erläutern,
die Herausforderungen herauszuarbeiten. Eines
hat sich jedenfalls gezeigt und das ist doch
eine wesentliche Folgerung für alle logistischen
Maßnahmen im Bereich von Streitkräften - die
Notwendigkeit einer gesamtheitlichen, integrierten
Planung. Einerseits im Vorfeld, aber auch während
eines Einsatzes, einer Operation, eines Krieges
ist wesentlich. Und zweitens, die Verfügbarkeit
eines Lagebildes. Die logistische Führung
muss zeitnah, permanent über ein aktuelles
Lagebild verfügen, um rechtzeitig Maßnahmen
der logistischen Bedarfsdeckung einleiten
zu können. Damit möchte ich schließen
und ich wünsche Ihnen noch alles Gute.